I think the most important thing about
an astronaut is is you know you have to
take four first of all take for a given
that person's done done pretty well in
school you know has has the intelligence
and all that to learn new systems and
new things but after that the most
important thing I think is being able to
get along with others you know
flexibility and teamwork those issues
because as we get fly longer and longer
in space those are really important
factors even on short shuttle missions
you know those are important factors to
put a crew together that can work
together effectively as a team that can
get along and so I think for an
individual you know I think the most
important thing is being able to work
with others
you know NASA interest in laying hadn't
done that much until fairly recently
because we'd always flown short missions
and we're all professionals and and the
thinking as well you know everyone get
along for a you know two-week mission
right so and everyone can so it hasn't
really been a problem the Russians have
been flying long duration crews since
the early 70s and in in the early days
they've ended at least two missions
early because of conflicts within the
crew so they learned early on the
importance of studying this and making
sure you put the right crew together
since our we began our work together on
the International Space Station with the
Russians in the you know early early
2000s we've started to NASA has started
to learn the importance of this kind of
work and so NASA is looking much more
into it and funding more work into this
through both directly by NASA as well as
through the NS PRI and so I think it's
important work and we are now fully on
board and recognizing that it's
important